this is the Upington white horse and it
is somewhere around 3000 years old it
was carved into this hill in Oxfordshire
before the British Isles had written
history so we have no idea who made it
or why and until humanity invented
aircraft millennia later no one could
even really see it properly the view
from the ground here isn't great we're
also not allowed to fly a drone over it
so you're gonna have to make do with a
satellite photo to see the whole thing
this is a 3,000 year old piece of art
and I am now going to smash part of it
with this hammer we're smashing a chalk
into the figure of the horse today to
preserve its appearance and keep his
longevity as people have done for the
last 3,000 years otherwise it wouldn't
be here we're taking new chalk from the
quarry just behind me about 50 meters
away ten tonnes in all and yes that's
been applied to the horse by the use of
a club hammer before that though the
horse is weeded or scoured for the old
traditional term so we can get on to the
bare surface we reach all can scale the
horse every year now they're all
volunteers previous years have been
years of neglect maybe 20 25 years but
traditionally back in Victorian times
every seven years but we're proud of the
horse here we want to keep it looking
its best as long as we can the Oxford
University back in the 1990's came out
with a newly developed sensor back then
which was able to determine the last
time sunlight touched the bottom of the
trenches on which the horse is founded
and that put it to what we know today
3,000 years ago this is by far the
oldest chalk finger in the country
nothing else comes anywhere near it we
don't know for sure about how the horse
was put in or for what reason we imagine
that there might have been a wooden
Tower constructed from which the seer
would be able to direct left right
missed a bit that kind of thing part of
the mystery or the enigma of the white
horse hill is what makes it so appealing
to people can come you can use your own
imagination what would happen if we
didn't chalk the horse I think it would
grow over within 20 or 30 years that's
what we say to the people that have been
kind enough to come along today and
helpers is that they're actually
contributing to living history here
without that without that human
intervention it would grass over 25 30
years and be lost forever this is art
that's been preserved by generation
after generation after generation after
generation repair and
keep that's been going on for millennia
through the Roman Empire the medieval
period a lot of invasions the English
Civil War the formation of the United
Kingdom all the way up to the
Information Age every so often groups of
people have come together on this hill
to preserve this it is a very real
connection with the folks who came
before us
smash it smashed it but nothing